the people who own the restaurant and
are making the food here
are healthcare workers working double
and then they come here and feed the
community
[Music]
oh hi marie
hi marie marie
how's work
she's a hard worker so
before you open the restaurant villa we
were nurses we are nurses in montana
hospital you know we're always hungry
from like a 12-hour shift so we always
like travel to like new jersey you know
to have like a filipino meal and it
takes a while to go like to queens or
jersey it will take us like at least an
hour and a half i mean we don't deserve
that i mean it's a long night shift so
maybe we can like at least comfort
ourselves by opening up a restaurant of
our own
my name is marcus dinapo
hi my name is joanne
my name is jude
and we are the owners of billau
[Music]
[Applause]
we survived the night
i started like seven o'clock last night
and i'm just getting off from work right
now
past eight o'clock this is actually
early
so we're up for like dinner or breakfast
and we're just craving for filipino food
so we're heading to bilal now
this food is really good dude i haven't
eaten all night to be honest i was so
busy this is like the perfect
food and like you can eat it like even
if it's like a breakfast meal you can
eat it any time of the day yeah i cook
this for dinner yeah i'm so hungry
we should have a get together with
everyone since we haven't done that in a
while oh yeah we should um i can
coordinate a party here and it's open
for everyone who works in the unit and
i'll bring some filipino stuff too so we
can taste some snacks
[Music]
woodside queens is the epic center of
the filipino restaurants here in new
york city i'm going to this filipino
market to pick up some snacks
everything is here
seems like i didn't leave home
when i first moved here usually my
family and i would you know dine in in
queens or you know do our food shopping
in queens there's a lot of filipino
restaurants filipino stores in the area
yeah this is joanne's favorite she
always brings this at work
always in any party of the filipinos
they believe it is when you have this
it's for long life because of the strip
of the noodles so as long as they have
like long strip noodles it's considered
like long life
this is actually one of the favorites as
well
but
it's really deadly it really contributes
to the hypertension
it's very sinful
us filipinos
we always have rice so
when we say breakfast it's a full meal
we didn't open to compete with any other
filipinos we just want to share how
comforting and good it is
this is for um the oxtail the highlight
of the oxtail is always the shrimp paste
otherwise
it's not gonna be knocked out
this is very good with a mix of beer
good for a party
[Applause]
i think i'm good to go
so right now the philippines produces a
lot of healthcare workers there's five
major hospitals around the area and
there's like about 2 000 filipino nurses
fair hospital
my mom worked the graveyard just like
they did
my mom worked 11 to 7 for almost 35
years
they took turns
bringing in dishes for everyone to eat
because there were so many filipinos
it's why we're here
the healthcare crisis in the late 60s so
you got a green card a working visa if
you were a healthcare practitioner
i think taking care of people is in
filipino in the filipino culture it's in
the blood
it's just like being able to take care
of somebody being able to look after
somebody it's it's it's in us that's why
we also are your nannies that's why you
go to central park and have those people
that are walking their stroller there
are all filipino were your nannies were
your nurses were your doctors were your
cruise ship attendants were here were
the guys who cooked food on the on the
cruises were the ones i mean this
restaurant itself it's it is based
around three healthcare workers
that are from the philippines you know
not like they're born here and became
healthcare workers they're born in the
philippines and here
i didn't eat today because
i knew i was going to get down with this
[Music]
oh [ __ ] they need this right here
i mean
so each one of these dishes comes with
rice
it's not an option
it just comes with rice
sizzling [ __ ] this is the best one
this is real filipino food
like this is real filipino food good
bits of pork typically from the head the
cheek and oddly enough this is a bar
food
that's banging
[Music]
each one of these dishes
is meant to share
it's a sharing culture
us nurses you know we take care of
people
the heart of the restaurant comes from
a taste from home like what we used to
eat back home in the philippines you see
when we have gatherings you'll see
there's a lot of bilal plates on the
table
and it's consists of big meals
so a good place for sharing to
meet with families with friends
i don't know how he has any time i don't
i don't
know he's in school too yeah
he's a nurse at two different places
thank you too
time management
so right now we have the pansit we serve
that in every party birthdays christmas
any occasion but it is always there
it's basically like a full meal because
it has everything in there
and then the next one will be pork
barbecue barbecue is like a filipino
staple it's just easy because it's on a
stick and you just walk around yeah
dude this is delicious
it's really good yeah you can see i'm
not talking a lot i'm very invested
right now
so yeah
and we love we love supporting our
co-workers we love them so i don't know
what it is we're just all so close
can i chose for an earlier year i mean
we had we had a tough year for the past
like
last year right
so
for everybody for a new beginning
[Music]
no matter what we do we're always going
to be nurses by heart i don't see myself
leaving the nursing profession yet i'll
be a nurse forever
the same goes for me i think nursing
will be my main focus until i retire
but this isn't just about money and
having a business
this is about feeding a community
this food here this restaurant is about
taking care of each other
they
are saving lives
they are saving not like figuratively
saving lives they are literally saving
lives every day and running a restaurant
and feeding a community
so it's a tall task
it's a tall task
[Music]
so
[Music]
you